all right let's go to our correspondence
now in the 2020 presidential election it
came down to the state of Pennsylvania
always a key State especially so today
it remains a hard state to predict
however our jurika Duncan has made her
way to Braddock Pennsylvania that's just
outside of Pittsburgh she's been
covering the race there jerika good
morning
good morning to you Tony I'm watching as
some cars are just coming into this
polling location of course both
candidates making their last-ditch
efforts and arguments late last night
Lieutenant Democrat Governor Lieutenant
Governor John fetterman who lives here
in Braddock and was mayor rallied
supporters in Pittsburgh yesterday
inside a packed carpenters union hall he
cast GOP opponent mehmed Oz as a wealthy
Outsider and told the crowd after his
stroke quote I've been knocked down but
I got up and he called that the essence
of this campaign on the other side of
the state Oz was in Pennsburg near
Philadelphia joined by former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley Oz argued
fetterman's positions are extreme and
said fetterman is soft on crime and
immigration meanwhile the line at
Philadelphia city hall was overflowing
with people yesterday trying to make
corrections to their ballot as the city
estimates 3 800 mail-in ballots are at
risk of being tossed for minor errors
the fetterman campaign has joined a
lawsuit with overturned the state
Supreme Court ruling that those ballots
with a missing or incorrect date
will not be counted both Republicans and
Democrat voters that I spoke to since
I've been here said that democracy is on
the line for them and with nearly 9
million registered voters here in the
Keystone State today will be a defining
moment as voters will have the power to
determine the future of the state and of
course our government as a whole Tony
yeah it's all in their hands the voters
are the ones that count today drika
thank you very much